oh endless hat hair
i didn't think this through
hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skincare nerd and
newly qualified cosmetic chemist yes
that's right i felt so awkward about
people accidentally calling me a
cosmetic chemist that i went off and got
a diploma that is how bad i am at
confrontation today i'm not quite
talking about sunscreen i'm talking
about things you can use instead of
sunscreen i can feel my sunscreen
propaganda shield box slipping away
right now
time to stop eating avocado on toast i
guess as much as we all love sunscreens
sometimes it is a bit of a pain in the
what what in the book you have to apply
it right you have to apply enough
sometimes they can give you rashes and
clogged pores they rub off they can feel
uncomfortable so it seems like there has
to be a better option right today we're
talking about hats and umbrellas i think
most of us have seen the swiss cheese
diagram which has to do with covert
protection there are lots of different
types of protection each one has some
shortcomings but if you have enough
layers of imperfect protection then they
can add up to give you overall pretty
decent protection and i think this is
how we should think about sun protection
as well sunscreen is one layer it's
imperfect it should be used in
conjunction with other things in
australia we have the slogan slip slop
slap seek slide slip on a shirt slop on
some sunscreen slap on a hat seek shade
and slide on some sunglasses but how
well does each one work why do we still
get burnt in the shade can we wear a hat
instead of wearing sunscreen let's start
by talking about where uv comes from it
obviously comes from the sun but there
are two different types of uv exposure
which you might remember from my video
about whether or not you need to wear
sunscreen indoors we have direct uv
exposure this is where the sun is
falling on your skin when you're in the
sun you have direct exposure when you're
in the shade you have indirect exposure
then there's indirect or diffuse uv
exposure this is where the sun's uv
bounces off something else onto you
usually that something else is air
molecules high up in the sky but
sometimes it's also the ground or other
objects around you this bouncing around
also happens with visible light which is
why you can still see things when
they're in the shade shorter wavelengths
of light get diffused more so there's
more diffuse uv around the visible light
and more diffused uvb than uva if you're
standing in the middle of an empty field
then out of all the uv coming in towards
you about 60 of the uv you're getting is
diffuse and 40
is direct these percentages are very
rough and they change with lots of
different factors like how high the sun
is in the sky where you are in the world
what time of year it is what wavelength
of light you're talking about but the
key thing is the uv shining directly on
you is actually less than half of your
total uv working out how much direct uv
you're getting is pretty straightforward
if the sun is shining on you then you're
getting that direct 40
working out diffuse uv is trickier we
need to work out how much stuff is
bouncing uv on us if you're outside the
main thing bouncing uv on you is
probably the sky we can use something
called sky view to work out how much uv
we're getting so if you're standing
outside in the middle of a field you can
imagine that you're surrounded by a dome
of blue sky that is 100 exposure to
diffuse uv and the amount of diffuse uv
you're getting is proportional to the
amount of sky that you can see if
there's stuff between you and the sky
then you have lower sky view and lower
diffuse uv if half of the sky is blocked
out then you're getting about half the
diffuse uv so if you're standing right
next to a building and you're standing
in the sun then you are getting that
direct 40 uv plus half of that 60
diffuse uv that gives you a total of 70
of the uv that you would get compared to
standing in the middle of a field if
you're not in the sun but half of the
sky is blocked so you're standing next
to a bun but the sun's moved and now
you're in the shadow that means you're
not getting the direct uv anymore you're
not getting that 40
but you are still getting half of that
60 you're getting 30 percent of the uv
you would be getting if there was
nothing else in the field now in some
situations the ground can also reflect
quite a lot of uv most surfaces absorb
most of the uv that comes in so this is
like grass dirt asheville apparently
americans call this bitumen but there
are some surfaces that do reflect more
so apparently in some countries there's
this thing called snow and that can
reflect up to 90 percent if you're
standing in this so called snow the snow
can actually bounce up more uv than the
sun in the sky combined sand can be 10
to 40 depending on the type of sand
concrete is around 10
so depending on the uv index even if
you're standing in the shade all of this
bouncy uv can still add up so that's why
you can still get burnt in the shade if
you're standing and you're facing the
sky or ground that can bounce up uv you
can still get a lot of uv and remember
uvb wavelengths get scattered more when
you're in the shade you usually feel
quite cool because visible light and
infrared which is 90 of the energy
coming from the sun
that's the stuff that heats you up and
it's getting blocked but that uvb can
still bounce around and get onto you
if you face away from the sun then the
uv bouncing onto your face is going to
be cut down by a lot even though you
feel around the same temperature wise so
hats and umbrellas basically portable
shade how much protection are we getting
let's start with hats
hats are usually made with thick
material that will block out almost all
the direct uv so an akubra hat which
looks like this blocks out everything
but one two thousandth of the uv so this
leaves 0.05 getting through but of
course if you have a hat made out of
thinner fabric then the uv is going to
increase you might remember my video
about upf clothing the same points apply
here so if you're looking for a hat that
blocks out more uv you're looking for a
synthetic fabric with really tight knit
basically you want really small holes
and as few holes as possible if you have
a few layers then that helps basically
the less breathable it is the better it
is intense colors are also better
because fabric dyes can absorb uv the
bigger the hat the more sky it's going
to block out and if the brim turns down
it's going to be a bit more protective
than if the brim turns up because you
can see more sky off the side so for
example this hat
is probably going to give better
protection than
this hat
even though they are around the same
size
but they do give you hat hair this is a
terrible hat for sun protection i don't
know why i bought it
i do because i was pressured to by space
nerds
if you're wearing a cap like this you
can imagine a little man standing on
your face
he's gonna still get a lot of sky view
it will be blocked over here but you're
still getting all of this plus you're
getting some direct uv every once in a
while as well shining on your face
but a little man standing here in the
middle of your head is going to get a
lot less guy view he can't see all of
the sky up here but even with a broader
brimmed hat there can still be a really
big difference so a little man standing
here near your forehead is going to get
a lot of sky view blocked out by this
bit
like that
hats don't work with fringes
so in general the forehead and the nose
get the least sun exposure the cheeks
and the chin get the most because
they're further away from the brim
they're not getting their view blocked
out by this brim as much as if they were
up here and for parts of your face that
are angled up with the hat is going to
block more a little dude lying on your
nose is going to get more stuff blocked
out by a hat than someone lying on your
face and looking sideways but of course
there's also the ground a hat isn't
going to protect you against uv bouncing
off the ground which could be a
significant problem if you're somewhere
like in the snow one study estimated
that with the sakura a farm worker in
queensland would drop down their yearly
exposure of uv down to one-seventh for
their thyroid one-third for their nose
but by less than a half for their cheek
their overall face protection factor was
two to six but in some parts of their
face it could be up to 100
now with umbrellas we can think of these
as like hats but further away from your
head the further away it is the bigger
it has to be to block out the same
amount of sky if the umbrella doubles in
distance from your nose so
maybe to here
then the radius has to double to give
the same amount of protection
one big difference between hats and
umbrellas is that umbrellas tend to be
made out of thinner materials so usually
more direct uv can get through and this
can be really variable in studies it's
been found that regular rain umbrellas
can let through as much as 23 of the uv
or as little as 0.1 percent
unsurprisingly given what we know about
fabrics from upf clothing black
umbrellas work the best and also
umbrellas that have a upf rating this
umbrella from uniqlo claims to be upf 40
which means it lets through 2.5 percent
of uv i'm not sure i believe the upf
rating for this umbrella but it's
supposedly bigger than 50 plus so
it should be letting in less than two
percent another difference with
umbrellas is you're usually off to the
side with an umbrella so one side of
your face can get a lot more uv and
depending on where your umbrella is and
how wide it is you could actually be
getting more uv exposure with your
umbrella than with a hat but on the
bright side you don't get hat hair
annoyingly for our purposes most studies
have been done on beach umbrellas which
are stuck in the ground and much bigger
overall in studies with beach umbrellas
you can get a projection factor of
between 3 and 17 depending on the size
of the umbrella where you are under the
umbrella the thickness of the umbrella
where the sun is and so on another study
estimated that if you're sitting in the
shade under an umbrella in the middle of
summer and you're not wearing any other
protection as illustrated by these
helpful but slightly creepy diagrams you
can still get burned in two hours so
here are the takeaways hats and
umbrellas are great for giving uv
protection that you don't need to
reapply and won't wear off quickly they
also project areas that you might not
easily be able to cover with sunscreen
or clothing like your scalp or like the
edge of your eyelids although there are
sunglasses for that that will be a
different video they're particularly
good for protecting against direct uv
but it's that 60 diffuse uv that gets
you these umbrellas and hats only really
protect the circle of sky right above
your head there's all of the edge where
stuff can bounce in to project against
diffuse uv you're going to need sideways
protection like a wall or trees to get
between you and the sky or you can go
for something that's closer to your skin
like sunscreens and clothing if you're
in a high sun exposure situation
remember the swiss cheese layers don't
just rely on one type of protection use
multiple types high sun exposure
includes going to the beach and
exercising in the sun in lower uv
exposure situations like if you're only
going outside for a few minutes or if
it's in winter unless you're in one of
those places that gets this snow thing
then you're going to need less layers of
swiss cheese so i hope this video was
useful you might also like my videos
about whether or not you need to wear
sunscreen indoors whether or not you
need to reapply sunscreen how to reapply
sunscreen my video on sun protective
clothing and maybe just my sunscreen
videos in general like subscribe
notification bell check out my blog
check me out on instagram and i will see
you next time for more nerdery